hello my name is Samira doctor professor
in CA and I just moderated a session on
technology innovation and welcoming
forum meeting station after he had a
very exciting session in which we first
focus called some of the key global
trends in technology and our panel
members mentioned that economically have
become kotaku III mini as Max is no
longer the primitive rich today we're
gonna run technology and technology is
also becoming much more global much more
intelligent and decided the garmin
connect to all of these trends is
creating a whole range of in a rage
society and people especially young man
if I using technology to heavy
eighth-grade venerated out the ignorant
in which way inconceivable given
some years ago and today we find that
many institutions will miss the
government's have to adapt the way they
interact in society of customers they
have to change the impeller our sleeves
and all the medical doctors to be able
to leverage the new potential technology
most important of all it would mention
that technology gives people hope and i
think it is this hope that we have to
cherish then dojo because ultimately
this is what we live from you sure the
technology will advance with translation
impact a normal person and the music
don't you have the DS longplay active
and constructive role in this process
thank you very much